d'ailleurs aux mains des aquanautes
album-là et du vin du vin à 10 heures du
matin
donc je regardais la télé ou quoi il ya
un ministre qui a dit que le vin est
pareillement de l'alcool à quai et donc
sur ta chemise là c'est pas vraiment du
vomi donc lui y'a pas longtemps le
ministre de l'agriculture digne et
guillaume anies ce truc je crois pas que
ma soutane et cause comme les autres
l'addiction à l'alcool est dramatique et
notamment dans la jeunesse avec le belge
week end c'est assez dramatique mais je
n'ai jamais vu là ma connaissance
malheureusement peut-être un jeune qui
sort de boîte de nuit et qui échoue
parce qu'il a vu du côtes du rhône du
crozes-hermitage alors je n'aime pas
dire du mal des ministres mais là c'est
complètement l'addiction à l'alcool
c'est pas se bourrer la gueule en boîte
et être alcoolique
ça a rien à voir avec le genre d'alcool
qu'on boit alain dire c'est pas une
histoire de qualité et c'est pas non
plus juste une histoire de quantité on
va voir les choses dans l'ordre
l'alcool de là c'est quoi au sens strict
l'alcool c'est un liquide qu'on obtient
en distillant des jus sucré fermenté et
qui contient essentiellement une
substance qu'on appelle l'éthanol ou
alcool éthylique dans le langage courant
l'alcool c'est devenu toutes les
boissons qui contiennent de l'éthanol y
compris le vin du coup désole didier
malheureusement peut-être alors la
particularité de ce brave éthanol c'est
qu'il a plusieurs particularités
d'abord il est psychotropes c'est à dire
qu'ils modifient le psychisme l'état
mental
si vous voulez ensuite il est très
addictif c'est à dire qu'on en devient
très facilement dépendant aussi bien
physiquement que psychologiquement ce
qui en fait une drogue c'est pas avoir
peur des mots
il est aussi toxique pour le système
nerveux le coeur les vaisseaux le foie
l'estomac etc
il provoque des maladies comme des
cancers l'ulcère la cirrhose la
pancréatite les hémorragies digestives
et j'en passe et des encore moins de
l'amour et en plus d'être toxique
physiquement il est aussi toxique
socialement l'alcool ça détruit pas
seulement la santé physique et mentale
de la personne qu'on boit ça détruit
aussi sa vie professionnelle et sa vie
de famille ça détruit sa vie quoi
et celle de ses proches aussi donc à
faire enfin quand je dis l'alcool fait
ça on se comprend on parle de
consommation problématique d'alcool et
c'est là que ça se complique un peu
alors si on fait un test si je vous
demande c'est quoi pour vous être
alcoolique il y aura à sion qui ne
répondait pas je ne vous entends pas
vous avez sûrement de donner un certain
nombre de réponses qui sont pas
complètement fausse mais qui vont sans
doute être un petit peu caricatural qui
n'est vraiment pas très sympa mais ne
prenez pas mal c'est pas contre vous
c'est la représentation collective de
l'alcoolisme qui est faussée et culturel
c'est normal c'est tout le monde
le problème c'est que cette vision
caricaturale la deûle alcoolique qui
était qu'un de complètement bourré du
matin au soir
elle a tendance à nous rassurer un petit
peu trop sur notre propre consommation
d'alcool moi je suis pas gouré du matin
au soir donc j'ai pas de problème
d'alcool
pardon mais c'est pas si simple à partir
du moment où vous buvait de l'alcool
potentiellement les problèmes commencent
dans la mesure où voire de l'alcool ça
représente un risque pour la santé
le risque qui peut être faible ou élevée
ou modérée mais il y en a toujours
ça peut aller de se casser la gueule et
se blesser ou avoir rapports sexuels non
protégés parce qu'on a vu et ça ça peut
arriver dès la première fois qu'on boit
jusqu'à choper un cancer la plus on voit
plus on doit souvent et plus on voit
longtemps puis on a de risques ça arrive
en passant par tout un tas de problèmes
de santé d'accidents de la route de
mauvais choix qui ont des sales
conséquences etc
et puis ça peut aussi être devenir
dépendant à l'alcool et ça c'est une
maladie une maladie qui a un côté
psychologique et un côté physique
physiologique parce qu'il ya plein de
phénomènes neurobiologiques qui entrent
en jeu et qu implique des substances
comme la dopamine le neurotransmetteur
du plaisir
la sérotonine le neurotransmetteur du
bonheur les endorphines etc mais aussi
des modifications au niveau du cerveau
on va pas rentrer dans le détail c'est
pas le sujet aujourd'hui
mais retenez que c'est une vraie maladie
une maladie dont la principale
caractéristique est la possibilité de
s'empêcher de voir de l'alcool
la tension s'est pas une maladie qui
arrive comme ça d'un coup genre tu te
couches ça va tu te réveilles barbe je
suis alcoolique non c'est pas comme ça
que ça se passe un ça s'installe
progressivement insidieusement sans
qu'on s'en rende compte
c'est aussi pour ça que c'est compliqué
a repéré parce que déjà la plupart du
temps on ne sait pas trop ce que c'est
mais en plus bas où on n'a pas trop
envie de savoir
et ça s'installe sans faire le groupe
bon mais alors comment on sait que
quelqu'un est dépendant à l'alcool
et bah c'est difficile parce que si on
me demande est ce que tu es capable de
s'arrêter de boire
la plupart du temps la réponse à m oui
il ya pas de problème j'arrête quand je
bon pendant un moment on disait si tu
bois au moins trois verres par jour tous
les jours
tes seins coniques et puis après on
s'est rendu compte que c'était pas aussi
simple que ça
retenez quand même qu'il ya une notion
de fréquence est une notion de quantité
en gros tout le monde et pas
complètement d'accord mais si sur une
semaine
vous buvez en moyenne plus de 3 verres
par jour si vous êtes un homme et +2 si
vous êtes une femme
considérez que votre consommation est
problématique ah oui et quand on parle
de verve reparle de verre standard c'est
à dire les doses qui sont servis dans
les bars pas les doses de pirates que
vous vous servez à la maison
[Musique]
dans un bar quel que soit l'alcool que
vous buvez vous avez la même quantité
d'éthanol dans votre verre parce qu'il y
en a autant dans un demi c'est à dire
dans 25 centilitres de bière que dans 10
centilitres de vin que dans trois
sentiers litre de whisky
du coup notez bien qu'on peut être
dépendant à l'alcool sans jamais debout
et parce que trois verres étalé sur une
journée concernant la quantité ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que l'organisme
s'habitue à l'alcool
donc il faut avoir des quantités de plus
en plus importante pour arriver aux
mêmes effets c'est ce qu'on appelle le
phénomène de tolérance mais comme c'est
pas juste une question de quantité et de
fréquences voilà dix trucs qui doit
allumer une petite lumière rouge dans
notre cerveau au sujet de votre
consommation d'alcool
[Musique]
vous buvez tous les jours vous buvez par
réflexe sans vraiment y réfléchir
vous buvez seul pas toujours mais
parfois vous buvez seul vous êtes
toujours en train de rechercher une
occasion ou un prétexte pour boire un
coup vous buvez pour vous sentir mieux
ou pour décompresser vous commencé à
boire de plus en plus tôt dans la
journée
vous assumez mal de boire voir vous vous
cachez ça vous arrive régulièrement de
perdre le contrôle et de boire plus que
vous aviez prévu
vous avez régulièrement des problèmes
parce que vous avez trop bu ce soit un
black out une gueule de bois
une blessure une impossibilité à faire
ce que vous aviez prévu de faire le jour
même ou le lendemain et malgré tout ça
vous restez rarement une semaine sans
boire
[Musique]
alors pas besoin d'avoir tous ces signes
mais si vous en avez juste un ou deux
commencent à vous poser des questions et
si vous en avez plus ce projet les
choses en oui parce que là on a beaucoup
parler de dépendance mais comme on l'a
dit au début il ya d'autres types de
consommation d'alcool qui sont aussi
problématique pour plein de raisons et
notamment parce que ça peut rendre
malade ou évoluer vers la dépendance
justement alors parmi ces consommations
problématiques il ya l'alcoolisation
massive régulière avec le binge drinking
et c'est bon mais qu'est ce qu'on fait
si on se rend compte qu'on a un problème
avec l'alcool
eh ben on se fait aider par des
professionnels et ça pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord parce que la dépendance
c'est un problème complexe avec des
implications physiques psychologiques et
sociales et que ça fait beaucoup à gérer
tout seul
ensuite parce que en plus d'essayer de
se débarrasser d'un truc autour duquel
notre vie tourne plus ou mois c'est bien
de comprendre pourquoi on en est arrivé
là pour essayer de régler le problème et
d'éviter que ça recommence
et enfin et peut-être même surtout parce
que se sevrer tout seul de l'alcool ça
peut être dangereux voire très bon jeu
un seul rage mal géré ça peut dégénérer
en delirium tremens ce qui contrairement
à ce qu'on pense ne consiste pas juste
avoir des éléphants roses c'est vrai que
ça implique des hallucinations
en l'occurrence on est plus sur des
insectes le delirium tremens et un
syndrome neurologique est causée par le
manque d'alcool et qui donne des sueurs
une agitation des tremblements une
incohérence et donc des hallucinations
mais aussi une déshydratation et une
accélération du rythme cardiaque et ça
peut être mortel
alors ça arrive pas à tout le monde et
il ya des signes qui permettent de
prendre les choses en main avant d'en
arriver là mais le mieux c'est quand
même d'emblée de se faire suivant avant
de se quitter bons
j'ai bien conscience que j'ai pas
répondu à la question que je pose dans
le titre de la vidéo
j'avoue le but c'était pas de vous
donner la réponse c'était de vous amener
à vous poser la question parce que ça a
l'air de rien mais c'est super important
et surtout parce que la seule personne
qui est vraiment capable de répondre
c'est vous alors bon comme maintenant
vous vous posez la question
eq c'est un petit peu à cause de vents
et quand vrai vous pouvez pas y répondre
comme ça tout seul je vous mets dans la
description de la vidéo un lien vers un
test qui va vous permettre d'évaluer
votre consommation d'alcool
faites moi plaisir faites le et si les
résultats sont pas claires clair
parlez-en à votre médecin ou appeler
alcoolinfoservice par exemple voient la
dtcc fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos
d'ici là prenez soin de vous et prenez
soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]